we humans like to get our heads around
all of the complexity around us by
classifying things and you can imagine
there's no more obvious thing to
classify than all of the living things
around us then all of the life that
arounds us so what I want to start
talking about is how do we classify all
of the life around us and this is more
often generally referred to taxonomy but
the most basic question you have when
you look at all of the life around you
you start to see similarities between
some of these living things you see
obviously this this this thing right
over here is more similar to the the
things that look like it than it does to
the grass behind it or to that tree and
so we start saying well maybe maybe I
should group this thing right over here
into a group with other things like it
and that most build at that very most
building block of how we classify all of
the living things around us is putting
them into buckets called species called
species so for example this is one
particular animal but we see other
animals that seem to look like it and so
we say they're all part of the species
of lions and this animal it's one animal
and there's other animals that have
stripes but some might be fatter or
taller or skinny or whatever else darker
or lighter but we say they're similar
enough but we call them all we call them
all tigers we call all the animals even
though they might be a little bit bigger
or skinny or fat or lighter or darker we
call all of them that have this kind of
they look similar to this thing right
over here we would call this we would
call this a donkey we would call this a
donkey we would call the things that we
think are like this animal right here a
horse now that might seem like a
straight pretty straightforward way to
think about it Oh everything that looks
kind of like this character right here
is a line anything that looks kind of
like this character right here is a
tiger but that by itself is not a good
enough definition for species things
that look like each other are things
that act like each other because what
we'll see is that there's some things
that could be very different at least in
how they look or act but are actually
closely related and we'll talk about it
what it means to be closely related and
then we can see things that look very
similar that they
have similar structures or they have
similar behavior like for example bats
and birds but they are actually all very
very distantly related so we need a more
exact definition for species than just
things that look like each other or just
things that act like each other and so
the most typical definition for species
are animals animals that can interbreed
that can interbreed interbreed and when
we say interbreed literally they can
produce offspring with each other and
and the offspring are fertile the
offspring are fertile which means that
the offspring can then have have further
have babies that they're not they're not
sterile that they that they're capable
of breeding with other animals and
producing and producing more offspring
and to show an example of this this
right here is a male lion you find a
male lion and a female lioness and most
of the time they will be able to have
offspring and those offspring can go and
mate with other lines or lionesses
depending on their sex and then they can
have viable offspring so it seems to
work out pretty well for lines same
thing is true of tigers
now it does turn out that if you get a
male lion if you have a male lion and a
female tigress female tigress they can
breed they can breed and they can
produce offspring and their offspring
which was made famous by Napoleon
Dynamite he was kind of fascinated by
these are kind of fascinating animals
their offspring is called a liger you
get a male lion breeding with a female
tiger you produce a liger which is a
hybrid ASIC cross between a lion and a
tiger and they're fascinating animals
actually larger than either lions or
Tigers are the largest cats that we know
of but these laggers cannot be referred
to as a separate species or you can't
say that mitt that lions and tigers are
the same species because even though
they are able to interbreed their
offspring for the most part is not able
to put is not fertile it's not able to
produce offspring there have been
one-off stories about ligers being mated
with either a lion or tiger but the
or one-off stories in general ligers
can't invert interbreed and in general
these this this combination isn't going
to produce offspring that can keep
interbreeding or that our fertile so
that's why we say that lions and tigers
are different species and that liger we
wouldn't even call it as a species at
all we would actually call it a hybrid
between two species now the same thing
is true and actually you might be asking
yourself well this was a male lion and a
female tigress what if we went the other
way around what if we had a female
lioness and a male tiger in that case
you would produce something else called
a tiglon or tag LAN actually don't know
how to pronounce that and that is a
different hybrid that has slightly
different properties than a liger
so tiger I encourage you to look up what
a Tai Glahn is similarly you give me a
male donkey you give me a male donkey
and donkeys are clearly a species by
themselves because if you give me a male
donkey and a female donkey they can
reproduce produce another donkey and
then that donkey can mate with other
donkeys to produce more and more donkeys
so not only can a donkey in to read with
another donkey but that that that
product that child donkey can then
interbreed with can keep interbreeding
with other donkeys
similarly horses they can interbreed and
produce fertile offspring but if you
give me a male donkey and a female horse
and a female horse they can mate and
they can produce a mule they can produce
a mule but once again like the ligers
mules are not at least as far as I know
mules cannot they're not fertile mules
cannot produce further offspring they
cannot interbreed with each other and
because even though donkeys and horses
can breed and produce mules their
offspring aren't fertile we don't
consider donkeys and horses part of the
same species and we would consider mules
like a liger or a tag line we would
consider them a hybrid so these are all
hybrids or we would call cross in
general the word hybrid is used when you
have two things of two different types
that are somehow coming together somehow
having a combination and once again like
the case with the tag line you might say
well what if I had a female donkey what
if I had a female donkey
and a male horse and then you would
actually produce something called a
hinny like a called a hinny which
similarly which isn't as common as a
mule and people like to use mules
they're actually very good work animals
because they they have some of the good
properties of both donkeys and horses
hinnies are less common but once again
it is possible and they have different
properties than mules and I do want to
emphasize this idea because when we
started off we just kind of try to think
about well how can we classify things
and we said hey maybe things that look
and act similar we can call a species
but I want to show you where or and
maybe things that looking act different
we shouldn't call them species but I
want to show you a very typical case and
one that's really all around us all the
time where this definition animals that
can interbreed and the offspring are
fertile really does be seemed to become
much much more important than just some
notion of animals that look alike or
animals that act the same and the best
example of that is with dogs and I said
this is a very typical species here
because dogs and I just took a sample of
some of the different types of breeds of
dogs they can look very very different
it's obvious look at look at the
difference between these dogs these for
example this little chihuahua here and
this dog right over here obviously their
size wise they look and even how they
act are almost are much much more
different than maybe how this donkey
would act relative to this horse or how
this line would act relative to this
tigress
and they obviously look look they look
very different they have completely
different sizes but these two things
actually can interbreed although for
these two in particular it seems like
the mechanics would get kind of
difficult but assuming they get over the
mechanical hurdles they could interbreed
and produce fertile offspring same for
these two characters same for these two
characters over here and because of that
even though all the different breeds of
dogs and all most of this is really due
to humans doings of trying to breed for
specific traits even though they look so
different and even though they act so
different because they can interbreed
and they can produce fertile offspring
we consider all of these things to be
members of the same species